some breaking political news this
morning that will likely distress tens
perhaps even dozens of people Democrat
Robert F Kennedy Jr will not be
Republican Donald Trump's running mate
in 2024.
can you definitively say you will never
run on a ticket uh for the White House
with Donald Trump
yeah in my experience
a lot of the stuff that you read in a
mainstream news in the corporate news is
what I would call conspiracy theories
[Applause]
you're dealing with an entire industry
made up of conspiracy theorists
and a direct answer to your question no
I will not be Donald Trump's vice
president
[Applause]
drats
of course he won't be Trump's running
mate
Bobby Kennedy Jr barely agrees with us
on anything it is fun to see him poke
Biden in the Democrats it is satisfying
to see him attack his own party over its
covid lies
that's pretty much it
Kennedy is with the conservatives on
kovid which is great but kovid is not
even a live issue anymore
if kovid were the big issue of this
election Ron DeSantis would be leading
the pack by a country mile but it isn't
kovid was awful
the issues at play however in this
campaign go even deeper with an open
border an all-out assault on parents and
a justice department attempting to
imprison the leader of the opposition
the question in this election is not an
ordinary political issue but a
metapolitical issue it's a crisis of
regime do conservatives have any
political rights left at all do we have
the right to run our candidates do we
have the right to pass our laws to trust
our institutions even just to raise our
own kids I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show really really
pleased to see
some proof I think that I was right
about Barbie which is that Bill Maher
hated it we'll get to that in a moment
first though this is my favorite take on
the crisis of regime just came out from
Roseanne Barr on Twitter she said the
propaganda here from the other side is
sad it's just a collection of unhinged
emotional outbursts from Trump
derangement syndrome Psychopaths who
only hate him because the war party
pedos told them to I've been mentally
ill my whole life and these people are
bat s-h-i-t crazy in comparison pretty
much sums it up
That's it man so if you think if you
think the issue in this in this campaign
is well you know those rates of illegal
immigration are a little bit High I
think we need to curtail those a little
bit you know I just think
I think that those corporations are
getting away with a little bit too much
we might need to regulate them a little
bit more then then you'll
probably try to pick from the ordinary
array of candidates and policies if
however you think that the issues of
play in this campaign are a little bit
deeper if you think that the the fact
that the current president is trying to
imprison his chief political rival is is
not just an aberration but a harbinger
of even more ominous things to come
then you're probably looking at the
election a little bit different and
you're not going to be a one-issue voter
covid or immigration or I don't know any
issue you're going to be looking at the
whole political order now Bobby Kennedy
Jr did just get one in endorsement that
would be from
Woody Harrelson lovable Woody Harrelson
great actor uh he posed with Bobby
Kennedy's wife Cheryl Hines who is the
plays the wife on Curb Your Enthusiasm
with Larry David which is funny because
Larry David's a huge lib and screams at
anyone who's even vaguely conservative
so this sums up the Kennedy campaign to
me the Kennedy campaign is for cool
hippies not ordinary hippies who are
generally insufferable
but cool lovable hippies like Woody
Harrelson
Bobby Kennedy's campaign is for Anodyne
populists people who recognize that
there is something wrong not just with
the Democrat Party not just with the
Republican Party there's something wrong
with the whole system the corporate
media the liberal establishment whatever
term you want to use for it but
they're Anodyne hippies because they're
not going to support a populist
candidate who can actually
gum things up
Kennedy is polling at what 17 percent in
the Democrat Party Democrat Party keeps
a much tighter lock on the primary
process than the Republican Party does
there is a zero percent chance that
Bobby Kennedy becomes the Democrat
nominee for president not going to
happen
but you can feel kind of good because
you say all right baby I'm voting
against the system it's like the people
who voted for Ralph Nader in 2000. it's
like a a glorified version of The Green
Party
now the populists who want to get
something done
they vote for Trump not that that's a
guarantee to get anything done it might
not they might not let him win either
but at least he he has won before at
least he has gummed up the system before
you see this a little more clearly
overseas
the populists who want to get something
done
vote for the brexit they vote for
Georgia Maloney although she has gone a
little bit squishy they vote for Victor
Orban in Hungary
they vote for the Vox party in Spain
they vote for uh
afd in Germany they vote for the
conservative party in Sweden they vote
for
these Insurgent groups that
actually have a shot of winning
but if you don't want to deal with that
you don't want to be called an evil
terrible monster racist this is status
then then you endorse Bobby Kennedy Jr
and you get you get to have your cake
and eat it too you don't you don't
actually get any consequence out of that
but you get to you get some populist
cred without having to deal with the the
downsides of that it is a crisis of
regime though and I don't think I'm
being hyperbolic about that you want to
know my evidence for it my evidence for
it is that the suicide rate just hit an
all-time high
that's probably the best evidence I
could give you that the problem we face
right now is not just one little area of
public policy has gone off
or one little part of the government has
become corrupt but that the whole system
is is really rotten the suicide rate or
in recent years has been getting worse
and worse and worse so much so that the
life expectancy in the United States has
declined because of deaths of Despair
overdoses and suicides and now
the suicide rate hit an all-time high 49
500 people killed themselves last year
in the U.S highest number ever
CDC has not yet calculated the official
suicide rate for the year the available
data suggests that suicide rates are
more common in the US than any time
since at least the dawn of World War II
largest increases were in older adults
deaths Rose nearly seven percent in
people ages 45 to 64 Rose more than
eight percent 65 or older and white men
in particular the most maligned group in
the entire country probably in the
entire world have very very high rates
this
tells you
that the argument of the unit party
everyone from the Clinton Democrats all
the way over to the Romney Republicans
has fallen flat and that argument we've
heard it a lot especially over the last
10 20 years is that liberalism is great
and on the right you hear Classical
liberalism is great we just need to
return to the enlightenment values and
on the left you hear liberalism is great
and we need to follow liberalism to its
logical conclusion and be more
Progressive and Kindler and gentler but
we're all going to follow the liberal
program of of what of prioritizing
material benefit which is fine we all
want to be able to eat but prioritizing
material growth over any other
consideration not at all considering the
other things that make a nation a nation
people customs language borders
Traditions all of that is what religion
most of all that's all bunk forget about
that that's for the from the Stone Age
We that that doesn't matter anymore now
we have iPhones and iPhones are all that
matters see and when you ever suggest
that maybe there's a problem in the
country a problem that goes a little bit
deeper than one party and goes to the
systemic level what you will hear from
the the line Towers on both sides of the
partisan divide is look things are
better now than they've ever been
deaths in infancy are way way down
they'll tell you look people used to die
in childbirth now those deaths are way
way down you might say yes that's true
because of modern Medical Technology the
problem is no one's having any kids
well okay sure but deaths from war and
violence they're way way down yeah but
people are killing themselves more than
ever oh okay yeah that's true well um
now people aren't stuck in abusive
marriages or marriages for politics or
economic considering that's true just
now no one's getting married
yeah and people are literally killing
themselves
so you it it reminds me of the
Socialists you know the Socialists will
always say look socialism it's it's just
never been tried
we'll say forget about all the all the
actual data on what socialism looks like
in practice let me tell you what it
looks like in theory and this is what
I'm hearing from the Liberals
modern Progressive liberals and
so-called classical liberals all the
same they're basically saying oh no true
liberalism's never been tried oh don't
look at the actual data don't look at
the people killing themselves don't look
at the families collapsing don't look at
the drug overdoses don't look at the
borders falling apart don't look at the
political structure no no just in theory
in theory liberalism is great who cares
if it works in practice does it work in
theory I care if it works in practice
and the millions and millions of
Americans
the many many millions of people across
the West who are voting for these more
populist parties who are questioning the
dogmas of official regime liberalism in
the last few years
we all care if it works in practice much
much more than what you can sketch out
on a chalkboard now when you want to
talk to people about these things you
got to check out pure talk right now go
to puretalk.com Knowles you know a
company is looking out for you when they
upgrade your service without even
charging you for it it's great news for
new and current Pure Talk customers pure
talk just added data to every plan and
includes a mobile hotspot with no price
increase whatsoever if you've considered
pure talk before but have not made the
switch take a look again for just 20
bucks a month you will get unlimited
talk text and now 50 more 5G data plus
their new mobile hotspot this is why I
love pure talk it's veteran owned they
only hire the best customer service team
located right here in the great us of a
most families are saving almost a
thousand dollars a year while enjoying
the most Dependable 5G Network in
America remember
you vote with how you spend your money
so stop supporting woke wireless
companies that don't support you when
you go to puretalk.com Knowles kwels
you'll save an additional fifty five
zero percent off your first month
because they value you
that's puretalk.com
Wireless for Americans by Americans
speaking of the uniparty liberal
establishment types Jonah Goldberg
is typifying this he's Furious that that
people aren't just going along with the
program Jonah came out with a book after
he had his his big split with the GOP
and the conservatives over Trump he was
one of the true and Veteran never
trumpers he like a lot of the
self-styled classical liberals wrote one
of these books about how everything
today is really great and all those dumb
stupid people in the middle of the
country need to shut up and stop
complaining because you know the the
Enlightenment and Classical liberalism
is just so wonderful and we just we
don't appreciate it enough and so Jonah
Goldberg is following this idea now to
its logical conclusion by complaining
about the uh fact that people Ordinary
People
have a say in the nominating contests
for the GOP he's complaining that
candidates are paying attention not just
to the big Mega donors on Wall Street
but to the small dollar ordinary donors
in on Main Street I just also to think
that we were dealing with a time where
there are a lot of people there was a
there was a lot of cheering and and
self-congratulation about the rise of
small donors a decade ago and now small
donors are actually one of the biggest
problems for democracy for the GOP
because
um small donor large donors actually
I have a strategic view about moderation
who can win who can't small donors
really are just venting their spleen
with their credit card and um and they
lock candidates into positions that can
hurt them in the general election
venting their spleen
the contempt just dripping from his
voice they're just these small these
small dollar donors which is to say
Ordinary People these Ordinary People
they're a real threat to democracy
this is the exact same thing Hillary
Clinton said these deplorable
irredeemable Ordinary People they're a
threat to our democracy because
sometimes they want something that I an
elite liberal do not want
and that's a big threat
Jonas actually taking the argument
further you've got to give them points
for at least being honest about his
views here where he's saying you know if
these campaigns were just decided by a
handful of billionaires on Wall Street
we'd be so much better off our democracy
would be so much healthier of course
that's an incoherent statement democracy
is government of of the People by the
people for the people
but he's showing you
that when liberals on the left and on
the right when they use that term
democracy when they complain because the
Hungarian people elected Victor Orban oh
no this is a threat to democracy how can
the people voting for someone be a
threat to democracy what they mean by
democracy
is liberalism
a very elite
theoretical ideology
that is have is having all sorts of
problems in practice
but to which these people cling with the
Zeal of the most Ardent converts and
proselytizers
of course
of course but it's not convincing people
and so when that argument doesn't
convince people then the Liberals on the
left and the right turn against the
people explicitly ASA Hutchinson's doing
exactly the same thing as Hutchinson who
I theoretically is running for president
he's the former Governor of Arkansas who
who became best known for insisting as a
quote-unquote republican Governor
insisting that we
in Arkansas ASA Hutchinson made the same
point
the fact is I'm not a self-funded
candidate and in the RNC rules is
burdensome on the candidates to instead
of focusing on other ways of raising
money and focusing on other styles of
campaigning I've got to spend all of my
time at the Iowa State Fair trying to
get on the debate stage with one dollar
contributions and so uh that's not
helpful and it's not good for our
Democratic process it's not helpful
to me that I can't just call a few
billionaires and then become the
president I have to go I have to talk to
those disgusting filthy people in in
Iowa
I got to go to the state fair and eat a
corn dog like a like a plebeian
can you imagine like a rough neck
disgusting peasant
and that's a big threat to I got to talk
to people
it's a big threat to our democracy if
I've got to talk to people to become
their president
notice where ASA Hutchinson made this
comment
did he say it on the daily wire did he
say did he say it on Tucker Carlson's
show
no you say it on the blaze did he say it
no
he didn't even say it on Fox News he
said it on MSNBC where did Jonah make
his comments I believe it was CNN
these these guys
were Republicans
even it pains me to see what's happened
to Jonah Goldberg because I used to
enjoy reading him sometimes
but
the moment that Donald Trump came in and
injected a little bit of nationalism a
little bit of populism into the national
conservative conversation all those guys
split
said nope no thanks I was willing to
play around with the Republicans for a
little bit when I thought that I could
steer the party in a liberal Direction
but now that I can okay I'm I'm
effectively a Democrat
I know Jonas I think still says he's a
republican as Hutchinson's running as a
republican for president doesn't have a
snowball's chance in hell but in their
practical lives where do they write who
funds them what TV channels do they go
on it's all
for the left the Liberty Russell Kirk
made this warning in the early days of
the post-war conservative movement when
there was the prospect of a fusion
between the conservatives and the
Libertarians Russell Kirk the great
conservative political philosopher
warranty said this is not going to work
out very well because a lot of those
Libertarians ultimately are gonna gonna
move to the left
which we've seen now speaking of small
dollar donors Mike Pence has gotten a
fair number of them and that's why he is
going to be on the debate stage for that
first debate so far that debate
you are going to have well Donald Trump
is qualified but we'll get to whether or
not he's going to be there in a moment
DeSantis has qualified he will be there
Tim Scott Nikki Haley Vivek ramaswamy
Chris Christie Chris Assante still has
hope Doug burgum I think has qualified
the North Dakota governor who is running
as a tax cutting Social liberal don't
think that's going to go very far but
Pence is qualified now too
and regardless of whether Trump shows up
or not
this is yet another reminder
that that something that a lot of
Republicans want to avoid is unavoidable
one of the one of the main complaints
I've heard from Republicans
regarding these debates and campaigners
we got to move on from 2020. we can't
keep talking about 2020. we got to move
on we got to move on
we can't
it won't happen I'm not telling you it's
a good thing or a bad thing I'm just
tell
this will be a relitigation of 2020. the
fact that Mike Pence is on that debate
stage
means that
a lot all of the questions to him are
going to be about his relationship to
Trump
and January 6th and whether that
election was stolen he was the vice
presidential candidate during the
contentious 2020 election
if Trump is on that stage can you even
imagine those two going at it
even if he's not on that stage people
are going to be attacking Trump or
attacking Pence
as a Lackey for Trump or for having
turned on Trump but there's no way to
avoid that
that is going to happen I'm sorry don't
shoot the messenger here I'm just
telling you that
the the contention that 2020 was stolen
is the reason Trump is running in the
race Trump is the leading candidate in
the race so people are going to have to
focus their fire on him either directly
if he's on stage or indirectly if he's
off the stage and if they're going to
focus their fire on him they're going to
focus the fire on 2020.
it's it we're stuck there baby the only
way out is through
you know what rhymes with through Prager
you which you got to check out right now
go to prageru.com many Americans have
lost faith in the government media and
schools that's the bad news the good
news is there's something that you can
do to help get the country back on track
prageru is an educational non-profit
that is fighting to save the future of
America watched five million times a day
prageru videos spread messages of
Liberty economic freedom and the values
that built our country to the Next
Generation there truly is hope for
America but only if we reach more young
people and prageru needs your help go to
prageru.com and make a tax deductible
donation whatever you give right now
will be matched and have twice the
impact donate ten dollars it doubles to
twenty give 50 it becomes a hundred you
get the idea seventy percent seven zero
percent of viewers say their mind was
changed after watching a prayer you
video please give to prageru today so
your gift can have double the impact in
reaching more people and changing more
Minds go to prairieu.com today a
whatever you give will be doubled my
favorite comment yesterday is from coz
Jr who says
Michael's team has always laid on the
Bell because Ben Shapiro's book The
authoritarian moment left them
speechless
foreign
moment not only Ben Shapiro's book but
my future campaign slogan it's gonna be
Knowles 2028 the authoritarian moment
that'll be a lot of fun
uh on the debate on the Trump question
Trump has now said he will not sign the
pledge
that he is required to sign
to support the eventual nominee
which means that
most likely he won't be in the debate
we're at 75 78 80 percent and other guys
are at zero one percent two percent
three percent you do say uh what's the
upside am I going to go up one point but
they could go up you know they're not
dumb people they're senators
their Governors their intelligent people
you have some very good people I think
you have some very good people and you
have some people I mean I have a problem
with the debate for another reason I
wouldn't sign the pledge why would I
sign a pledge of people on there that I
wouldn't have I wouldn't have certain
people as you know somebody that I'd
endorse so they want you to sign a
pledge but I can name three or four
people that I wouldn't support for
president so right there there's a
problem
of course of course he's not going to
sign the pledge before anyone out there
who hates Trump who is supporting
another candidate
before you shoot the messenger
I'm not saying it's a good thing I'm not
saying it's a bad thing I've told you
I'm the last GOP conservative
commentator in America who isn't
actively working for one of the
campaigns
I'm just describing to you what is
happening
and I'd like to point out
I'm doing that not because I don't have
thoughts and even some preferences in
the campaign I'm doing that because I
think it's much more interesting to just
tell you what I what I say I'm doing
that because it allows my predictions to
hate to say I Told You So tend to be a
little bit more correct I think than
some other people's predictions in the
campaign and
because
politics
is largely about leverage and Power
it and so you could be angry you'd say
well Trump is a coward for not okay
Maybe
but why would he show why would he sign
the pledge to say that he'll support the
eventual nominee
well what about party Unity Trump
doesn't care about party Unity Trump
launched a hostile takeover the
Republican Party
2016 was a hostile takeover he's not a
lifelong Republican he doesn't have any
loyalty to the Republican Party he took
it over and he was able to take it over
because a lot of Republicans don't have
that much loyalty to the Republican
party because they felt the Republican
party was corrupt and not giving them
results so that's off the table well
because
he
he he should want to debate to present
his case to the voters it's
disrespectful yeah maybe if his poll
numbers were lower then he would have to
do that but his poll numbers are very
high so he doesn't have to do that
well I just think it's wrong of him okay
maybe you might think it's wrong sure
but
unless
Trump has an incentive to debate
unless he has an incentive to support
the eventual nominee
he's not going to do it
and so that's that and you can whine and
complain and pull your hair out over it
but that's just a fact that's politics
and if you if you don't like that then
you should stop following politics to me
that's some of the most interesting
stuff are these power games and who's
got the leverage and who's where people
are in the chess board I I find that
very engrossing I find it delightful no
matter who the candidate is that that's
quite interesting to me
but if you're just viewing the campaign
through a lens of why isn't why aren't
things turning out the way I want them
to why aren't things going the way I
predicted well then you should check
your priors you should check your
premises
because if your predictions are
consistently wrong
then it means that there's something a
little bit off about the way you're
viewing viewing the game
now outside of presidential Politics the
former Arizona GOP gubernatorial nominee
Carrie Lake
is apparently stepping off Staffing up
for a senate campaign
this would be the campaign to take
Kirsten cinnamon seed Kirsten Cinema is
a Democrat but she's kind of moderate
and she's now an independent
so she's running as an independent
you've got a a Democrat now who's
running Ruben Gallego
and you've got a Pinal County Sheriff
Mark Lamb who's running as a republican
Kerry Lake might challenge him to be the
Republican nominee
uh this this also makes sense
Carrie lake has to run for something
because she needs to set herself up to
be the vice president
security like has been not so subtly
campaigning to be the vice presidential
running mate with Donald Trump but right
now she's just a lady who lost a
gubernatorial election so she she needs
something to give her the credibility to
take that position the Arizona senate
seat would make a lot of sense speaking
of women
I'm going to try to get through a lot of
stuff before we get to the mailbag today
uh Dr Charlotte proud man what a name
Couldn't Write it better out of
Hollywood uh just went viral for a
message she had to pregnant women she
said a message to pregnant women please
give the baby your surname you carried a
baby for nine months gave birth and will
be responsible for that child for the
rest of your life when you're
registering the baby ask yourself why is
the Father's surname more important than
yours
okay I've I've heard this some people
have written in with this question
should
we
you know have families with one name
should women take their husband's name
should the kid have the father's name
there's three reasons why they should
the husband is the head of the household
as such everyone should have his name
it's a family unit okay maybe you think
that's a little too old timing and
traditional For You Second reason women
carry the baby women have a very close
connection to the baby the man's
relationship to the baby you know it's a
relatively quick contribution and so
with the baby taking the man's name it
joins these two things together
the man will never have the physical
bond with the baby that a mother has but
they will be a family unit they will
have his name
but the third reason
why Dr proud man lady is so wrong here
is that that baby will inevitably have a
man's surname
the baby will either have his father's
last name or his maternal grandfather's
last name she's saying a message to
Spring women please give the baby your
father's surname
instead of your husband's surname which
doesn't make a lot of sense at all but
if you're doing this from a feminist
perspective
you can't have it's going to be a man's
name now you might say well I'm a
millennial and I actually I took my
mother's I have my mother's last name
okay
and my my mother actually she had her
mother's lesson okay okay go up two
generations you're gonna get to a guy
pretty pretty
quickly
before we get to the mailbag
Bill Maher
Bill Maher says
that Barbie was terrible he said okay
Barbie I was hoping it wouldn't be
preachy man-hating in a zombie lie alas
it was all three what's a zombie lie
something that never was true but
certain people refused to stop saying it
uh tax cuts for the rich increased
revenues for example or something that
used to be true but no longer is but
certain people pretend it's still true
Barbie is kind of a zombie lie it goes
on this whole long essay he hated Barbie
I rest my case
you know I had a little bit of a debate
with arpel Ben Shapiro and some other
conservatives this real Barbie really
split the conservative movement
and
now that Bill Maher says that Barbie was
terrible I rest my case
that it was terrific
there were some people pointing to Bill
Maher's commentary and saying see this
this proves it Barbie was bad
Bill Maher is wrong about pretty much
everything
but
I think I'm so glad Bill Maher disagrees
with me that's how I know I'm right and
and this ties into something we were
talking about a little bit earlier
which is a deeper issue here and that is
Bill Maher is a liberal he's a he's a
progressive liberal but he's styled
himself in recent years a slightly more
classical liberal I don't know classical
meaning he's a liberal from the 90s and
some conservatives some people on the
right have really gone along with this
some of the squishier people on the
right they say oh I agree with Bill
Maher on all sorts of things
that's a problem
Bill Maher is
an atheist libertine who
maybe will say wokeness has gone too far
or something if that's the best
conservatives can do if the best
conservatives can do is conserve 90s
liberalism then let's just hang it up
folks if we cannot offer an alternative
political vision
if we're if the moment that someone does
offer an alternative political Vision we
just cut and run and go whine on MSNBC
and CNN then just hang it up then there
are no conservatives in America
if you can't recognize that Bill Maher
is wrong about the most important things
he's funny I like I like Bill Maher he
invited me on a show one time I didn't
make it uh maybe I'll I'd be happy to go
on again I like him in some ways it's
kind of funny but he's wrong about
everything
and if a conservative can't acknowledge
that you know
come on
then you probably don't even realize
that Barbie's a good movie okay
Candace just wrapped the 10 part series
convicting a murderer that you will not
want to miss
it's one of our most ambitious projects
yet
you might think that you're familiar
with the Steven Avery case and
everything that happened in Manitowoc
County did I pronounce that correctly
this is especially true if you watched
making a murderer but it turns out the
filmmakers only told you part of the
story coming soon Candace Owens will
unveil the shocking parts of Avery's
story that were omitted in the Netflix
series quite excited to present the
convicting a murderer trailer check it
out
this is a collect call from an inmate at
the Calumet County Jail a man served 18
years in prison until DNA evidence
cleared his name the two rivers man was
convicted of sexual assault in 1985 but
exonerated with DNA evidence in 2003. so
this is the infamous Avery lot now two
years later he again finds himself tied
to a police investigation accused of
murdering Teresa halba on the Avery
property Steven Avery's 16 year old
nephew admitted his involvement in the
rape and murder of Teresa halbuck the
car is discovered just around the bend
was just this worldwide phenomenon I
think they framed this guy I think he
intended to crush the vehicle but ran
out of time Avery thinks the 36 million
dollar lawsuit he filed is why he's
being targeted in this investigation
[Music]
Netflix made millions of dollars from
making a murderer but the filmmakers
left out very important details
mountains of evidence that you have not
yet seen the blood vial the most
egregious manipulation from the movie
interrogations that's when he started
beating me because I told him that he's
sick cell phones and I saw melted
plastic parts of a cell phone interviews
her arms were pinned behind her head
they made Steven Avery look like a
victim you believe your brother is
guilty
I don't know if I'm a suspect I've been
on high
sick and tired of media deception
evidence hiling off why would they omit
so many different things why are you
editing my testimony
I am not going to make the same mistake
that the filmmakers did
rearranging the testimony the delete a
portion of it at the end how could they
claim to care about the truth they all
know that Steven Avery committed this
crime
emergency
the evidence forces me to conclude that
you are the most dangerous individual
ever to set foot in this courtroom
it looks pretty good to get the rest of
the story you have got to watch
convicting a murderer coming to you this
September this 10-4 series is exclusive
to daily wire plus so join now at
dailywire.com subscribe get 25 off your
new annual membership so you can watch
convicting a murderer when it premieres
trust me
you do not want to miss this
and now finally finally we've arrived at
my favorite time of the week when I get
to hear from you in the mailbag the
smell bag is sponsored by Pure Talk go
to puretalk.com
get 50 off your first month
take it away
howdy howdy once again Mr Knowles it
slapped my base once again coming at you
with another question so my church band
has been asked to play the Assumption of
Mary's ceremony at our local church next
Wednesday and what I wanted to ask you
is can you explain what the Assumption
of Mary is I'm not very well versed in
these holy holidays as you know and
would like to know a little bit more
about it I realized I could probably
save a lot of time by just researching
it myself on Google but it's a lot more
fun when you explain it to me plus I
like hearing your dulcer tones much like
I'm pretty sure you like hearing my
delicious bass stones and my music
anyway love your input love your show
thanks again
excellent question and an excellent
Feast uh the short version is that the
Assumption of Mary refers to the the
bodily Assumption of Mary the Mother of
God into heaven if you want to go find
Mary's body on Earth you know open up
Mary's tomb discover her remains you
will not do that because Mary is in
heaven this
uh is a Dogma this is a Dogma that was
defined relatively recently it was
officially defined in the Catholic
church in 1950 I think it was by Pope
Pius XII in munifichi munifi
chantisimus Deus I believe is the
document in which he defined it
um but but the tradition goes back much
much further to the very earliest days
of the church uh this is a view not only
held by Catholics it's held by the
Eastern Orthodox obviously by the
lutherans at least the lutherans were a
long time held it I don't know if they
still do or how many of them still do
the anglicans believe in this
um
it was it's not uh required if you're an
Anglican to believe in this it's
considered something indifferent but uh
many anglicans do believe in this the
feast was preserved for a long time uh
Bollinger the uh the successor is vingli
and Zurich among the Protestants he he
believed in the Assumption of Mary so
the idea is that uh our Lord would not
let his mother's body just simply Decay
on Earth but uh assumed her this belief
is attested to it at least as early as
the
5th Century maybe the fourth century and
then there's an oral tradition that goes
back basically to the time of the
Apostles
um but we've got very very strong
evidence of it still from way back in
Antiquity so anyway that's the view and
a lot of people don't even know about it
today even though the vast majority of
Christians for all of history have
believed in it okay next question
greetings dear executive grassy Knolls
for a long time now I've questioned the
titles used to differentiate American
Generations you have Generation X myself
being a Generation Y excluding the
Millennials preceding to Generation Z
what were we counting down toward now
I'm no conspiracy theorist but now that
I know that generation Alpha will be the
first majority non-white generation was
this planned since the 70s
no
it was planned since the 60s
and is is that you're not allowed to say
that because if you say that they call
you a conspiracy theorist and a racist
and everything but what's funny is the
Liberals frequently will say that they
will I mean there was a very famous
event in 2004 very famous political
science paper that talked about this new
ascendant Coalition of non-white people
and how politically advantageous this is
going to be for Democrats and it goes
back to the 60s because of the 1965
heart seller immigration bill which said
basically we're going to open up the
borders and dramatically flood the
country with new new immigrants and that
this will change the demographic makeup
of the country and this will uh since it
was passed by democrats this will
presumably redound to the benefit of
Democrats so that was planned as for the
naming of the generations
you know it might just be one of those
happy coincidences all Natures but art
unknown to thee although if you look at
the way that uh masculinity is going in
the country perhaps generation beta is
a prophecy rather than just a
coincidence next one
hi Michael my name is Evan I've been a
long time fan of your show I'm sending
this question today about Ronald Reagan
who's a figure I think on which we
disagree I want to know why you and so
many other figures on the right venerate
Ronald Reagan as some kind of Icon and
hero of our movement when in reality he
actually did a lot of things wrong like
when he was governor of California he
signed the nation's first no fault
diverse divorce law and a law that
required permits to carry loaded guns in
public while he was President he signed
the 1986 immigration reform and Control
Act which legalized over sixty thousand
illegals just while he was President as
well as differing deportation for
another hundred thousand illegals
uh he also appointed Bush seniors as
vice president and tried to play nice
with the libs saying that we have no
enemies despite the fact that they were
already committing industrialized baby
murder
uh he was also famous for his
intervention overseas
um after his presidency he signed a
letter supporting Clinton's assault
weapons ban
um but in short I think that Reagan was
just another squishy Republican who gets
too much credit for being patriotic
while he actually worked to undermine
the country like so many of our
Republican leaders now I just want to
know your thoughts
well I don't I don't venerate Reagan I
do admire Reagan and and I don't deny
any of the things you've said
he was far from perfect he did a lot of
things that were wrong but I think
you've got to put the guy in his
historical context first of all you you
knock him for picking bush
he picked Bush to unite the party and I
think you grant that he picked Bush
because Bush was a liberal Republican
and Reagan was the representative of the
conservative Republicans
and he was conservative for his time I
mean don't forget he was he ran against
Jerry Ford in 76 and he ran against
Jerry Ford
who Ford had a lot of problems but he
was quite left-wing I mean the guy was
promoting the Equal Rights Amendment
this feminist Madness that would have
obliterated sexual difference much
earlier in this country than it happened
so
you know I talked to yorum hazoni about
this the Israeli political philosopher
and he said I know Reagan gets knocked a
lot now but at the time it really felt
like a Revival
at the time it really felt like a
religious revival and The Madness of the
60s had been so so intense that there
was a lot of climbing back to do and I
just give the guy a little bit of Grace
for doing what he could do in his time
especially he was governor of California
and then when he was president without a
republican Congress
I I agree he did all sorts of things and
probably held views you know in fact I
know he held some views that I would
disagree with but I think he played his
part
I can't think of a viable conservative
who who would have done better in his
time
so I give him credit for it you know but
I agree I don't think we should you know
try to exhume his corpse
reanimate his zombie body and you know
have him run for president again he did
his part in his time
now we have to do our part in our time
next question
hey Knowles I have a question about
reading
what should I be reading as a Catholic
to further understand the faith better
other than the Bible the catechism what
authors would you recommend I read I
know you talked a lot about Saint Thomas
Aquinas C.S Lewis uh Chesterton what
books should I read and do you have a
full reading list if you do that would
be amazing I don't have a full reading
list but I probably should make one I
was I was asked to make one the other
day for an outlet that I should probably
do uh you mentioned the catechism I
would recommend reading the catechism of
Saint Pius X it's a really short one
it's very quick that you can read Saint
Pius X great guy and you can get it on
online for like five dollars and it's
it's quite good
and would seem to be a little more
precise than maybe catechisms that have
come later I would recommend for
Chesterton reading Orthodoxy I would
recommend reading uh anything by Hillary
bellock is just so delightful because
he's so acerbic in his prose I would
write yeah I mean you you could open up
the summa theology it might be a little
little bit much to take in at once but I
don't know I just sort of dive in
sumacontra Gentiles maybe is more
approachable I would recommend Saint
athanasius on the Incarnation I would
recommend the writings of of Saint John
Henry Newman apologia pravita sua is is
probably his master work the idea of a
university is really really good I
recommend the writings this is a little
more contemporary of Father George
rutler I really like him
um is a friend of mine and he's an
excellent writer I would recommend oh
goodness I don't know there's just so
much to read it's a good place to start
though
let's see
some written mailbox
I would like some advice on a matter I'm
newly engaged to a wonderful man I love
the idea of having a traditional wedding
ceremony my only problem is that my
father hasn't been active in my life I
barely saw him as a child and even in my
adult life I rarely see him it's rare
for him to show up even to family
holiday Gatherings my stepdad was the
one who raised us and was there to
support us through our lives he sadly
passed away two years ago my dilemma is
about who should walk me down the aisle
on my big day should an absent father be
given this honor or would it be better
to somehow honor the man who would have
been given that duty if we were given
time
it's a really tough ones already here
for that that you've got that dilemma
and that your stepfather died had he
lived and he were your adoptive father
you know he would he's the man who
raised you then it would seem clear
enough he should probably be the one to
walk you down the aisle since he is gone
though and since it sounds like you've
got a deadbeat for a father
um
I would still tend toward the idea that
that your father walks you down the
aisle even if you don't like him even if
he's a bum
I think that you know the the wedding
ceremony is a Public Act it's it's
liturgical it's
quite traditional and I and you'll have
a better life if you forgive your father
for being a bum
and one way to do that
is to not turn your wedding into a
protest of him if if he's going to show
up to the wedding at all and maybe
that's up in the air but if he's going
to show up to the wedding at all I would
have him do it it's not about honoring
him personally it's about
honoring the role of the father
and it's you know a wedding is the
beginning of your new family and it's
making a statement about the family that
the family is stronger even than the
individual and flawed personalities
within it so for those reasons I would
give your father
that role even if he doesn't deserve it
okay now
there's something coming out there's
something coming out
this weekend that I am not even allowed
to talk about on YouTube
the thing that is coming out
will be will Air it's a very long
interview it's a Michael and episode it
will air on daily wire Plus
and it will air on Twitter at M Knolls
show this interview is apparently so
radioactive according to the sensors at
YouTube that I can't even show you a
trailer I can't even tell you the title
of this interview we shot it a little
while ago I'm trying to figure out how
to release it it will be released on
daily wear plus so make sure you go
check out daily word plus I think it'll
be up there potentially for free so
anyone can see it even if you're not a
daily wire member but you have to deal
with a bunch of ads and a bunch of
nonsense uh it'll be a daily word Plus
it'll be on Twitter at M Knolls show it
involves a certain issue
that we're not allowed to talk about on
YouTube and it involves an angle on that
issue
that very very few people are talking
about it it's I I'm not surprised
that YouTube has taken such a strong
stance against this because I think this
kind of perspective really
guts the
political ideological movement that
we're not allowed to talk about do you
catch my drift also it's fake headline
Friday I need your help with that the
rest of the show continues now head on
over to the Ellie wire.com use code
Knowles you will see on the member block
you will see the trailer for this
interview uh dailyr.com use code Knowles
check out for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
oh